look at the diagram below that answer
the following question what type of
angle is the angle highlighted in the
green below so it looks like two
anteaters going after an ant right over
here and this anteater is going straight
down or at least on my screen looks like
it's going straight down and this
anteater is going straight to the left
and so it looks like these this one's
going straight down this one's going
straight to the left it looks like this
is a right angle or a 90 degree angle
and so if i had to pick between any of
these it looks most like a right angle
looks like this is exactly going down
and this is going exactly to the left
that this is a 90 degree angle here if
this was an acute angle then the angle
between them would be smaller so maybe
this top one would be coming in from
this direction right over here for his
obtuse this angle would be larger so
let's check check our answer and try to
do a few more of these
which of the angles labeled in the
diagram below are acute angles so just
as a reminder an acute angle is less
than 90 degrees
so let's see a and b sorry a and c
both look larger than 90 degrees but b
and d both look less than 90 degrees so
b
i'll go with b
and d are the acute angles here
let's do
another one of these what type of angle
is the angle highlighted in green below
well this angle is less than 90 degrees
if it was equal to 90 degrees this thing
would come out like this so this is
clearly less than 90 degrees this is an
acute angle
let me just do one more this is a lot of
fun
select a symbol from the drop down menu
to complete the following statement then
answer the question below
angle a
is less than 90 degrees
less than 90 degrees what type of angle
is angle a
so angle a it's less than 90 degrees so
an angle less than 90 degrees is an
acute angle if it was exactly 90 degrees
it would be a right angle if it was
larger than 90 degrees it would be an
obtuse angle so i will go with acute
angle
we got it right